Ahora se recorre el mismo camino que estos primeros artistas.
Y en este lugar surrealista de otro mundo,
es casi posible imaginar
escuchar las sordas pisadas de botas de piel en la tierra blanda,
o ver el parpadeo de una antorcha en la siguiente curva.
Cuando estoy en una cueva,
a menudo me pregunto qué llevó a estas personas a ir tan profundo,
a desafiar pasajes estrechos y peligrosos para dejar su marca.
Este videoclip,
que se tomó cerca de medio kilómetro bajo tierra
en la cueva de Cudón en España,
encontramos una serie de pinturas de color rojo en el techo
en una sección previamente inexplorada de la cueva.
Conforme nos arrastrábamos estilo militar, el techo se hacía cada vez más bajo,
finalmente llegamos a un punto donde el techo era tan bajo
que mi marido y el fotógrafo del proyecto, Dylan,
ya no podía enfocar el techo con su cámara réflex digital.
Así, mientras me filmaba
seguí el rastro de pintura roja con una sola luz
y una cámara compacta que teníamos para ese tipo de situación.
A medio kilómetro bajo tierra.
De verdad.
¿Qué hace alguien allí abajo con una antorcha o una lámpara de piedra?
(Risas)
Digo yo, bueno, tiene sentido, ¿cierto?
Pero ya saben,
es el tipo de pregunta que trato de responder con mi investigación.
Estudio parte del arte más antiguo del mundo.
Creado por estos primeros artistas en Europa
hace entre 10 000 y 40 000 años.
Y el hecho es
que no solo lo estudio porque es hermosa,
aunque sin duda lo es.
Lo que me interesa es el desarrollo de la mente moderna,
de la evolución de la creatividad, la imaginación, el pensamiento abstracto,
acerca de lo que significa ser humano.
Mientras que todas las especies se comunican de una manera u otra,
solo los seres humanos realmente lo hemos llevado a otro nivel.
Nuestro deseo y la capacidad de compartir y colaborar
son responsables en gran parte de nuestra historia de éxito.
Nuestro mundo moderno se basa en una red global de intercambio de información
posible, en gran parte, por nuestra capacidad para comunicarnos,
en particular, con el uso de formas gráficas o escritas de comunicación.
La cosa es, sin embargo,
que hemos estado construyendo sobre los logros mentales
de los que vinieron antes de nosotros durante tanto tiempo,
que es fácil olvidar que ciertas habilidades no existían.
Es una de las cosas que me parece más fascinante,
sobre el estudio de nuestra historia profunda.
Esas personas no tenían hombros de gigantes para subirse.
Eran los hombros originales.
Y un sorprendente número de invenciones importantes
provinieron de ese tiempo lejano,
y hoy quiero hablarles acerca de la invención de la comunicación gráfica.
Hay tres tipos principales de comunicación,
hablada, gestual, así como la lengua de signos,
y la comunicación gráfica.
Lo oral y lo gestual son por su propia naturaleza efímeros.
Se requiere un contacto estrecho para que un mensaje se envíe y se reciba.
Y después del momento de la transmisión, se ha ido para siempre.
La comunicación gráfica, por otro lado, desacopla esa relación.
Y con su invención, se hizo posible por primera vez
que un mensaje se transmita y preserve
más allá de un solo momento en un lugar y hora.
Europa es uno de los primeros lugares
donde empezamos a ver signos gráficos con regularidad
en cuevas e incluso en algunos sitios al aire libre.
Pero esta no era la Europa que hoy conocemos.
Era un mundo dominado por altas capas de hielo,
de tres a cuatro kilómetros de altura,
con llanuras de hierba y tundra congelada.
Era la era de hielo.
En el último siglo se han encontrado
más de 350 sitios de arte rupestre de la era de hielo en todo el continente,
decorados con animales, formas abstractas e incluso humanas
como estas figuras grabadas de Grotta dell'Addaura en Sicilia.
Nos brindan una mirada poco común
sobre el mundo creativo y la imaginación de estos primeros artistas.
Desde su descubrimiento,
los animales han recibido la mayor parte del estudio
como este caballo negro de Cullalvera en España,
o este bisonte púrpura inusual de La Pasiega.
Pero para mí, las formas abstractas, los llamados signos geométricos,
fueron lo que me llevó a estudiar el arte.
Lo gracioso es que en la mayoría de los sitios
los signos geométricos son mucho más numerosos que los animales y humanos.
Pero cuando empecé en el 2007,
no había ni siquiera una lista definitiva de cuántas formas hay,
ni había un sentido fuerte
de si aparecieron los mismos a través del espacio o el tiempo.
Antes de que siquiera pudiera empezar a trabajar en mis preguntas,
mi primer paso fue recopilar una base de datos
de todos los signos geométricos conocidos de todos los sitios de arte rupestre.
El problema era que mientras estaban bien documentados en algunos sitios,
por lo general los que tenían animales muy bonitos,
también hubo muchos donde era muy vago,
no había mucha descripción o detalle.
Algunos de no se habían visitado en medio siglo o más.
Estos fueron en los que me concentré para mi trabajo de campo.
En el transcurso de dos años,
mi marido Dylan y yo pasamos más de 300 horas bajo tierra,
caminando, arrastrándonos y retorciéndonos en alrededor de 52 sitios
en Francia, España, Portugal y Sicilia.
Y valió totalmente la pena.
Encontramos glifos nuevos, indocumentados en el 75 % de los sitios que visitamos.
Este es el nivel de precisión que sabía que iba a necesitar
si quería empezar a responder esas preguntas más grandes.
Así que vamos a esas respuestas.
Salvo un puñado de signos atípicos, solo hay 32 signos geométricos.
Solo 32 signos
a lo largo de 30 000 años y en todo el continente europeo.
Ese es un número muy pequeño.
Ahora bien, si eran garabatos o decoraciones al azar,
esperaríamos ver mucha más variación,
pero en cambio encontramos los mismos signos
repitiéndose en todo el espacio y el tiempo.
Algunos comienzan fuerte, antes de perder popularidad y olvidarse,
mientras que otros signos son invenciones posteriores.
Pero el 65 % de esos signos se mantuvo en uso durante ese período de tiempo,
cosas como líneas, rectángulos, triángulos, óvalos y círculos
como vemos aquí desde el final de la era de hielo,
en un sitio de hace 10 000 años en los Pirineos.
Y si bien ciertos signos están esparcidos por miles de kilómetros,
otros signos tenían patrones de distribución mucho más restringidos,
con algunos que se limitaban a un solo territorio,
como vemos aquí con estos rectángulos divididos
que solo se encuentran en el norte de España,
y que algunos investigadores han especulado
que podría haber sido signos de familia o clan.
En un comentario aparte,
hay un sorprendente grado de similitud en el arte rupestre más antiguo
del que hay entre Francia y España e Indonesia y Australia.
Muchos de los mismos signos aparecen en lugares tan lejanos,
especialmente en ese rango de 30 000 a 40 000 años,
y está empezando a parecer cada vez más probable
que esta invención en realidad se remonta a un punto común de origen en África.
Pero eso me temo, es un tema para una futura charla.
Así que de vuelta a la cuestión que nos ocupa.
No cabía duda de que estos signos eran significativos para sus creadores,
como estas esculturas en bajo relieve de 25 000 años
de La Roque de Venasque en Francia.
No sabemos qué querían decir, pero la gente de la época, sin duda lo sabía.
La repetición de los mismos signos, por tanto tiempo y en tantos sitios
nos dice que los artistas hacían elecciones intencionales.
Si hablamos de formas geométricas,
con significados específicos, culturalmente reconocido y acordados,
podríamos muy bien estar viendo
uno de los más antiguos sistemas de comunicación gráfica en el mundo.
No hablo acerca de la escritura todavía.
Simplemente no había suficientes caracteres entonces
para representar todas las palabras de la lengua hablada,
algo que es un requisito para un sistema completo de escritura.
Tampoco vemos que se repitan con suficiente regularidad
para sugerir que eran una especie de alfabeto.
Pero lo que sí tenemos son algunas intrigantes excepciones,
como este panel de La Pasiega en España, conocida como "La Inscripción"
con sus marcas simétricas a la izquierda,
posibles representaciones estilizadas de las manos en el medio,
y lo que parece un poco como un corchete a la derecha.
Los sistemas más antiguos de comunicación gráfica en el mundo,
la cuneiforme sumeria, los jeroglíficos egipcios, la escritura china más antigua,
todos surgieron hace entre 4000 y 5000 años,
y surgieron de un protosistema anterior
compuesto de marcas de conteo y representaciones pictográficas,
donde el significado y la imagen eran los mismos.
Así que una imagen de un pájaro habría representado ese animal.
Es solo después de que estas pictografías se vuelven más estilizadas,
hasta casi volverse irreconocibles
y también empezamos a encontrar más símbolos inventados
para representar todas esas otras palabras que faltan en la lengua,
como pronombres, adverbios, adjetivos.
Así que sabiendo todo esto,
parece poco probable que los signos geométricos de la edad de hielo de Europa
eran verdaderamente caracteres escritos abstractos.
En cambio, lo que es mucho más probable
es que estos primeros artistas también estaban haciendo marcas de conteo,
tal como esta hilera de líneas de Riparo di Za Minic en Sicilia,
así como la creación de representaciones estilizadas
de las cosas del mundo que les rodeaba.
¿Podrían ser los signos de armamento o vivienda?
O ¿qué serían objetos celestes como las constelaciones?
O tal vez incluso ríos, montañas, árboles, características del paisaje,
como este signo peniforme negro rodeado de formas de campanas extrañas
del sitio El Castillo en España.
El término peniforme significa "en forma de pluma" en latín,
pero ¿podría ser en realidad una representación de una planta o un árbol?
Algunos investigadores han comenzado a hacer estas preguntas
acerca de ciertos signos en sitios específicos,
pero debemos volver a examinar esta categoría en su conjunto.
La ironía en todo esto, por supuesto,
es que después de haber clasificado todos los signos en una sola categoría,
tengo la sensación de que mi siguiente paso consistirá en dejarlo de lado
conforme se identifican y separan diferentes tipos de imágenes.
No me malinterpreten,
la posterior creación de la escritura completamente desarrollada
fue una hazaña impresionante por propio derecho.
Pero es importante recordar
que esos sistemas de escritura tempranas no salieron de la nada.
Y que incluso hace 5000 años,
ya se estaba creando sobre algo mucho más antiguo,
cuyos orígenes se remontan a decenas de miles de años,
a los signos geométricos de la edad de hielo de Europa y mucho más allá,
a ese punto, en el fondo de nuestra historia colectiva,
cuando a alguien se le ocurrió la idea de hacer una marca gráfica
y cambió para siempre la naturaleza de la forma en que nos comunicamos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)